Do you ever feel uncertain about the path you're on? Because you're not where you want to be or maybe you're sitting there
Second-guessing your own potential and feel as though you're not smart original or talented enough
This is going to sound strange, but you're doing it right. These experiences are normal
It's only when you stop questioning and become complacent about where you are that stops you from dreaming boldly
Here's seven strange signs. You will be successful
1. You know what you want even though you don't know how to get to it yet
Have you ever been so sure of something that you're constantly bursting with energy?
perhaps you knew you always wanted to be a dancer ever since you were given your first pair of ballet flats or
Maybe staring up at the night sky as a lost lonely
Teenager made you curious about what is beyond the empty void of adulthood that motivated you to become an astronaut
You can be absolutely sure about what you want. But you may not know how to necessarily obtain your dreams yet. And that's okay
You're starting somewhere, and that's what counts
2. You're easily bored and love challenges
We often identify traits like novelty seeking that can lead to behaviors such as gambling drug abuse and ADHD
But according to Dr Robert Cloninger
A psychiatrist who develop personality tests for measuring this trait, novelty seeking is what keeps people happy healthy and creative
Cloninger States to succeed you want to be able to regulate your impulses while also having the
Imagination to see what the future would be like if you tried something new when you're easily bored. It doesn't necessarily mean you're unmotivated
Instead you have the potential to grow when you seek new experiences that allow you to make the most out of your creativity
3.  you don't maintain a work-life balance
Instead you just focus on life. What does it mean to just focus on life? As humans,
We try to systematically organize by categorizing different aspects of our lives. So they don't spiral out of control
But instead of working on neatly giving everything a place to belong
It's easy to get fixed on the small details that we forget about the bigger picture
Being successful means going with the flow and doing what you feel is best for your mental health your friends family and coworkers
Although a certain degree of discipline and getting into a rhythm that works for you are important
It's also essential to make the most of every day
Being successful also doesn't necessarily translate to 40-hour work weeks
It's all a matter of finding purpose and meaning in what you do on a daily basis
4. You practice empathy look out for your teammates and celebrate the happiness of others
Although it's exciting to be motivated in what you do, successful people don't just stitch and forget about the people around them
Success never happens alone. It's always a collaborative effort
If you have great people skills, often look out for your teammates and empathize with others then you're already on a great path
Society often paints the workplace to be a dog-eat-dog world, but competition doesn't hold meaning when people can't learn from one another
It's important to refrain from adapting self-absorbed habits and learn to reach out as much as possible
Be supportive of each other's dreams and help each other to achieve them
5. You practice humility again and again
You don't focus on your achievements or constantly want to prove yourself to others by finding opportunities to be in the spotlight
Instead, you just want to get better not for an audience
But for yourself when you work on improving your skills behind the scenes your work journey becomes much more authentic
Because your progress is only for you to see.
It's not about the A you earned on a test that's pinned to the classroom board or the amount of likes you receive on social media
You care about progress because you genuinely want to get better, not to perform better
6. You're not motivated by money as a reward, but rather see it as a resource
You don't care about making the big bucks
Just to be able to afford extravagant possessions such as fancy cars or attend special functions like cocktail parties
in fact
you see it as almost a slap in the face that
Success can supposedly be measured by something that can be spent just as easily as it is earned
Yes. Earning money is necessary for survival, but you don't allow it to be everything
instead you focus more on earning money to give back to your community of
Supporters and your team members hard work and to buy resources or Ford experiences that help sustain and grow your business
projects and passion
7. You don't believe in dream jobs instead you believe in hard work
Persistence is key
People often say there's no such thing as fairytale love. The same goes for success
Rather than daydream about the possibilities of what your ideal career entails you go out and actively work towards building it
Overnight success is a myth. In order to reach your goals
You understand that sacrifice hard work and failures are all essential components of the journey
In fact, that's what makes it all the more worthwhile
If success was easily handed to you without a single day of sweat or tears, it would be hard to find meaning in it
But you also realize that success isn't everything. In fact, it's just a moment. When you realize that it's a humbling experience
Because you understand that success doesn't amount to much without the respect and love you have for yourself and others
What are your dreams do you experience any of these signs?
let us know in the comments below if
you like this video be sure to check out our website and other social media as well as our patreon account for more content as
Always don't forget to subscribe and thanks for watching